voilà je vous propose de commencer notre
audition je vous remercie de vous être
rendu disponible les uns et les autres
pour participer à cette nouvelle
audition de notre commission d'enquête
sur l'efficacité des politiques
publiques en matière de rénovation
énergétique nous vous recevons
aujourd'hui donc vous êtes les
représentants des trois organismes la
Fédération française du bâtiment qui
représentait par son vice-président
Monsieur Franck Perrault également
président du Conseil des professions de
la Fédération française du bâtiment mais
également vous êtes accompagné de
Monsieur
Eric Durand qui est directeur des
affaires techniques Fédération française
du bâtiment
constitué de fédérations territoriales
et de chambre syndicale la Fédération
française du bâtiment défend 50
000 entreprises adhérentes dont 70%
sont des entreprises artisanales qui
représentent les deux tiers de la
production annuelle du secteur la
Confédération de l'artisanat et des
petites entreprises du bâtiment la CAPEB
et représentée ici même par Monsieur
Jean-Christophe repond son vice son
président pardon et par Monsieur Henri
ALNA duffreté qui est donc secrétaire
général la CAPEB est une organisation
patronale représentant l'ensemble du
secteur du bâtiment mais défend
particulièrement les intérêts des TPE et
des PME elle fait partie des quatre
confédérations composantes de l'Union
des entreprises de proximité l'UDP enfin
le Conseil supérieur de la construction
était l'efficacité énergétique et
représentée par son président Monsieur
Christophe carrèche institué en 2015 le
Conseil supérieur de la construction et
de l'efficacité énergétique actuellement
placé sous l'autorité du ministre de la
Ville et du logement il a pour mission
de conseiller les pouvoirs publics dans
la définition la mise en oeuvre et
l'évaluation des politiques publiques
relatives à la construction et sur
l'adaptation des règles relatives à la
construction aux objectifs de
développement durable messieurs dans vos
différentes fonctions que je viens de
rappeler vous intervenez aussi bien sur
des sujets concernant des constructions
neuves que des interventions de
rénovation énergétique bien que la
construction neuve ne soit pas dans le
champ de notre commission d'enquête il
est important de noter qu'à long terme
elle joue un rôle très important dans la
performance énergétique globale des
bâtiments et dans l'atteinte des
objectifs de neutralité en 2050
par ailleurs que ce soit en termes de
technologie de matériaux de filières de
formation et d'entreprises les deux
sujets sont intimement liés beaucoup
d'entreprises font les deux je voudrais
aussi souligner que pour répondre aux
besoins de logement la construction
neuve conserve toute sa place à côté de
la rénovation à ce titre il nous serait
utile d'avoir votre retour d'expérience
sur la mise en oeuvre progressive de la
re 20 20 et votre position sur les
discussions en cours à Bruxelles sur la
future directive sur la performance
énergétique des bâtiments
concernant la rénovation énergétique qui
est le cœur du sujet de notre commission
d'enquête qui naturellement nous
mobilise pour l'essentiel nous aimerions
connaître votre position sur les
dispositifs d'incitation mise en place
par la puissance publique ma prime
rénove les C2E mais aussi les
dispositifs d'accompagnement France
rénov mon accompagnateur Renov quel a
été l'impact de cette politique tant en
termes d'offres que de demande sur le
secteur du bâtiment enfin nous avons
conscience que la mise en place d'une
nouvelle réglementation et l'atteinte
d'objectifs de rénovation globale
nécessite une formation du secteur quel
besoin
identifiez-vous comment transformer la
contrainte et l'objectif de
décarbonation et de sobriété
énergétiques en opportunité économique
et industriel pour la faire du bâtiment
et pour l'emploi voilà avant de vous
laisser la parole pour répondre à ses
premières questions il me revient de
vous indiquer que cette audition est
diffusée en direct et en différé sur le
site internet du Sénat qu'elle fera
l'objet d'un contre-endu je dois
également vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et
434-15 du code pénal qui peuvent aller
de trois ans à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et
de 45000 euros à 100000 euros d'amende
je vous invite donc à prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
a levé la main droite et à dire je le
jure comment peut-être par vous monsieur
le Président repos et puis à tour de
rôle
et bien je vous en remercie donc je vous
laisse la parole je ne sais pas comment
vous souhaitez vous la distribuer et
puis ensuite notre rapporteur vous
posera un certain nombre de questions
complémentaires à celle que je viens de
vous poser dans mon propos introductif
et nos collègues qui sont membres de la
commission permanente pourront également
bien sûr vous poser les questions
qu'elle souhaite puisque ce sont des
dames qui sont présentes dans cette
salle pour les membres de la commission
voilà donc je ne sais pas est-ce que
vous voulez commencer
par la Fédération du Bâtiment monsieur
Caresche allez monsieur caresse
monsieur le Président Karachi merci
ouais merci écoutez peut-être un mot
peut-être d'introduction sur l'ensemble
du dispositif
qui est mise en oeuvre aujourd'hui dans
le cadre de la transition
écologique
puisque en réalité depuis
quelques années deux ans et demi trois
ans trois ans il y a eu une activité
réglementaire très intense autour de
cette question que ce soit dans le
domaine de la construction vous avez
évidemment cité l'aéron 2020 qui est un
qui sera la réglementation qui est
d'ores et déjà d'ailleurs la
réglementation structurante en matière
de construction
j'ajouterai l'arrête d'échelle même si
elle est pas totalement dans notre dans
notre SCOP en termes énergétique mais
elle aura un impact très important aussi
sur le secteur plus d'autres
réglementations mais c'est les deux
principales à mon sens dans la
rénovation énergétique de la même
manière il y a eu aussi une activité
réglement très importante avec le fait
de bâtir en fait une architecture pour
la rénovation énergétique avec
évidemment au premier plan le DPE mais
aussi les accompagnateurs enfin
l'ensemble du dispositif ma prime rénove
vous l'avez cité qui a été mis en place
moi le sentiment que j'ai aujourd'hui au
moment où vous je vous parle c'est que
ce socle réglementaire a été mis en
place encore une fois à travers une
activité réglementaire très très intense
nous avons donné au csc2e je crois plus
d'une trentaine d'avis chaque année ces
dernières années donc c'est c'est tout à
fait considérable
avec un petit paradoxe d'ailleurs
puisque nous sommes censés être saisis
être garant de la simplification
énergétique et peut-être qu'on n'a
jamais connu autant de une activité
réglementaire aussi élevée bon ce qui
est pas toujours facile évidemment pour
les organisations donc vraiment dans un
dans un minimum dans un dans un temps
extrêmement contraint quand même
ce socle le réglementaire a quand même
été a été mise en place avec des débats
très importants je vais d'ailleurs au
passage saluer le travail qui a été fait
par les fonctionnaires notamment de la
DHP qui est vraiment tout à fait
remarquable ça n'empêche pas qui encore
aussi un certain nombre évidemment de
réserves que le CSC de jeux a exprimé
sur un certain nombre de ces de ces
dispositifs mais je dirais
qu'aujourd'hui le socle réglementaire il
est là maintenant le sujet c'est
vraiment la mise en œuvre l'application
et donc là avec toute une série
évidemment de d'inquiétudes
d'interrogations que les organisations
exprimeront beaucoup mieux que moi mais
je crois vraiment que maintenant le
voilà le l'étape qui est devant nous
devant les pouvoirs publics c'est
vraiment de faire en sorte que ces
dispositif réglementaire qui selon moi
est assez performant
puisse être mis en œuvre
la Fédération française du bâtiment oui
merci donc concernant les
réglementations sur la construction
neuve le grand changement était bien sûr
l'aéro 2020 puisque c'est la première
fois qu'on complète carbone dans lac de
construire jusqu'à maintenant c'était
uniquement la réglementation thermique
et donc c'est quelque chose de nouveau
que l'on a que l'on a assez vite
assimilé et avec cette R20 où on voit
nettement des produits bio sourcés de
plus en plus présent et gérer le monter
en compétences dans nos entreprises sur
le suivi sur la gestion des interfaces
sur ces sur ces nouveaux matériaux et
surtout comment apprendre à travailler
ensemble donc ça je crois que c'était
vraiment la grande révolution sur le sur
le neuf ce qu'on peut dire ce qui est
très important sur notre parle pas assez
c'est que lorsqu'il Revin va été mis en
place on a normalement tous les trois
ans une clauses de revoyure pour voir
justement si on est capable d'atteindre
les objectifs et je pense que ça c'est
quelque chose qui est très important
concernant maintenant la sur la ré sur
la rénovation énergétique donc toutes
les différentes mesures dont vous avez
parlé ma prime rénov les c2o etc c'était
à font tout pour je dirais pour
massifier la rénovation énergétique mais
surtout à destination des passoires
thermiques en tout ce qui a été fait
c'était vraiment pour les passoires
thermiques voilà donc on voit que il y a
eu plus alors on est on est au
rendez-vous on se rend compte quand même
qu'on n'est pas à la hauteur de ce que
l'on entend puisqu'on parlait de 700 000
rénovations lourdes on va dire on est
plutôt aux alentours de 70 000 voilà
donc ça c'est un constat
on en reparlera je pense après mais
c'est le premier constat et puis le et
puis le deuxième c'est qu'on voit bien
que il y a eu on a eu au départ le site
ensuite ma prime rénov et donc là elle
est vraiment axée sur les sur les sur
les ménages les plus modestes voir
modeste donc c'est vrai que c'est un
petit peu changé parce que dans le cas
de la cécité c'était plutôt des je
dirais des foyers aisés qui
connaissaient bien défiscalisation donc
quelques changements et puisqu'on peut
constater également pour nos pour nos
entreprises du bâtiment c'est qu'il y a
eu un petit peu également des des
différents sujets des coups de pouce
assez fort je parle par exemple de
l'isolation des combles voilà donc il y
a eu un peu des choses qui ont été
poussées de manière très forte le site
pour les fenêtres également ensuite on a
un petit peu revenu dessus donc c'est
vrai que pour nous entreprises de
bâtiments on aimerait bien avoir une
vision assez claire de ces aides et
encourager nos entreprises et puis
ensuite je pense qu'on parlera ce qui a
été également très très important pour
nous c'est le nos entreprises qu'on lui
suivent des formations pour être RGE et
puis après je pense qu'on en reparlera
plus précisément après sur ce RGE avec
quels sont les contrôles comment ça se
met en place et puis ce dont on parle
beaucoup et qui est important pour nous
son infraction du bâtiment c'est la
naissance des cours d'élinquants et
l'arrivée d'acteurs qui ne sont pas
forcément des entreprises de bâtiment
voilà ce premier stade le premier
constat sur ces nouvelles
réglementations
merci merci monsieur le Président de la
CAPEB pour la CAPEB donc l'artisanat du
bâtiment et exclusivement à casier je
dirais Martinière du bâtiment et c'est
62000 adhérents juste
un signal qui était envoyé au niveau des
des particuliers sur les dispositifs et
qui sont pour nous importants mais là on
rejoint la Fédération radio du bâtiment
mais le CTE permettait aussi d'amener
d'autres ménages dans dans la démarche
dans la défiscalisation et qui pour le
coup à jouer un peu un effet contrasté
puisque
avant la hausse de l'énergie il n'y
avait pas encore eu de cette vision de
d'économie d'énergie pure que que la
hausse de l'énergie a mené à mener à la
réflexion des ménages tout ce qui
est sorti de l'aéro 20 et plutôt
positive mais
il n'empêche que on parlait de
simplification c'est pas le cas et on a
plutôt complexifié la chose même dans
deux buts plutôt louable si on en plus
la décarbonation qui est encore un
nouveau sujet qu'il faut aussi traiter
on a rajouté des strates assez
importantes qui font que le coût le coût
du chantier a augmenté et vous on a de
16 actuellement dans le temps dans les
médias la crise du logement mais pour
partir la hausse de l'énergie la hausse
des matériaux depuis plus d'un an avec
plus de 26% d'augmentation des coûts des
matériaux fait que la contrainte
supplémentaire qui est qui est louable
et qui est sur la transition énergétique
fait que on a une facture globale je
dirais qu'on n'a pas jugé mais qui fait
qui a augmenté qui sûrement amène les
particuliers et les ménages à revoir
leur investissement et c'est ça que je
pense le frein à l'investissement le
frein à la au crédit qui qui est le plus
prégnant dans tous ces démarches là nous
bien évidemment qu'on ne peut que louer
l'effort qui a été fait dans le bâtiment
sur une vision de transition énergétique
et il faut qu'on y participe fortement
avec beaucoup d'innovations et beaucoup
de prise en charge mais il fait que la
facture pour le client final n'a cessé
d'augmenter depuis plus de deux ans et
c'est sûrement un effet boomerang qu'on
a actuellement quand on parle de la
crise du logement au quotidien après on
reviendra si vous voulez bien sur ma
prime rénove et les points d'évolution
ou de simplification
définitive qu'il nous faudrait pour que
ça soit une réussite puisque pour nous
on ne juge pas cela comme une réussite
il faut déjà plus de moyens pour pouvoir
la dynamiser encore un peu plus mais il
faudrait aussi simplifier définitivement
le marché pour pouvoir avoir plus
d'entreprises qui rentrent dans la
démarche
alors on va tout de suite passer la
parole à Monsieur le rapporteur et puis
après on pourra revenir sur certains
points et je reviendrai également
monsieur le rapporteur oui merci merci
madame la Présidente merci déjà pour vos
premières
explications
peut-être des questions d'ordre d'ordre
général enfin vous savez que vous avez
parlé de l'aéron qui est effectivement
on va dire un changement quand même
assez important depuis la RT 2012 qui a
à la fois modifié la manière
d'appréhender à la fois la construction
vous avez pas des matériaux biosourcés
mais du coup qui a accès sur sur le neuf
c'est vrai que
notre notre commission on était vraiment
sur la rénovation mais du coup je
voulais peut-être savoir justement
comment en fait cette orientation donnée
sur par la r2020 a peut-être permis
aussi de modifier à la fois certaines
pratiques en termes de formation
d'adaptation à certains matériaux et
comment cette adaptation là on peut la
retrouver aussi sur des chantiers de
rénovation
puisqu'on se pose aussi ces questions là
en termes de en termes de rénovation
mais je fais le lien aussi notamment sur
le confort thermique d'été ou c'est
quelque chose sur lequel on réfléchit
aussi et on s'aperçoit qu'en fait pour
l'instant c'est quelque chose qui est
peu pris en compte en tout cas sur les
sur les chantiers de rénovation en tout
cas sur les analyses et sur le le
notamment le DPE par exemple qui qui
n'en tient pas quasi pas compte on va
dire et c'est vrai que ben il y a
notamment assez matériaux biosourcés etc
on sait que ça peut être des éléments
qui sont assez importants donc peut-être
avoir votre réflexion justement comment
et puis derrière ça aussi la question
des filières qui peuvent se mettre en
place et en gros savoir aussi comment
vous pouvez être en capacité tout ça
c'est aussi des questions qu'on se pose
à la fois d'intégrer
ces nouvelles filières ces nouveaux
types de de matériaux
et puis aussi en termes d'absorption
aussi de d'un marché assez conséquent
puisque vous l'avez dit si on
de faire 700 000 rénovations globale par
an et qu'en tout cas c'est un objectif
c'est très bien de se donner ses
objectifs là il y a la question
financière puis après la question de
savoir comment on fait quoi et comment
on peut le comment on peut le réaliser
techniquement à la fois non merde en
termes de en termes de main d'oeuvre en
termes techniques etc donc voir comment
justement vous voyez cette cette
projection parce que c'est que ça ne
pose aussi des questions sur la montée
en charge aussi des dispositifs en fait
pour pouvoir pour pouvoir absorber ce
chantier peut-être aussi une question
sur le dispositif dans un petit peu
parlé mon accompagnateur Renov
comment en fait c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose qui qui débute comment en
fait vous quel œil vous le voyez et
comment il peut il peut vous penser
qu'il peut venir s'intégrer donc on va
dire dans dans la chaîne de de à la fois
de préconisations et puis le lien avec
avec vous et puis c'est vrai qu'on a
parlé aussi d'un dispositif mon
accompagnateur pro
à destination des des petites
entreprises qui pourraient avoir mais
qui sera un petit peu le pendant et qui
pourrait permettre justement de faire ce
lien avec des petites entreprises et
d'assister ces artisans et ses petites
entreprises à pouvoir suivre justement
des chantiers de rénovation donc voilà
avoir un peu votre votre avis là-dessus
sachant que c'est vrai aussi que dans
les différentes auditions qu'on a fait
notamment sur le la qualification et sur
le RGE c'est vrai qu'on s'aperçoit qu'on
a alors après on interroge mais qu'en
tout cas on a on a quand même beaucoup
d'entreprises qui qui se détournent du
RGE
et des entreprises souvent qui sont
plutôt compétentes et qui font des
travaux parce que elles ont déjà leur
réseau et que en Juan n'y voit pas le
l'intérêt donc aussi comment vous vous
voyez aussi cette cette qualification
RGE derrière après savoir est-ce que par
exemple on pourrait imaginer ou de enfin
on donne ces ce RGE à des entreprises
mais c'est qu'on pourrait se dire qu'on
peut avoir une formation à la base
beaucoup plus importante et qui
suffirait enfin c'est ce qui existe dans
d'autres dans d'autres pays voilà
comment vous voyez ça et de quel œil
vous pouvez voir voir ça et comment en
fait on fait en sorte aussi que des
entreprises qui sont plutôt plutôt
qualifiées plutôt compétentes répondent
peut-être encore plus justement à ce
type à ce type de chantier notamment le
chantier de rénovation voilà pour une
première série de questions je me
permettrai juste si vous pouvez nous
dire à peu près ce que représente le
marché de la rénovation dans vos
secteurs d'activité par rapport à celui
de la construction et est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un marché que vous
avez vu en forte progression ou pas donc
voilà alors monsieur le Président
caresse vous vouliez prendre la parole
un mot sur la sur l'aéro 2020 parce que
je pense que c'est une une
réglementation c'est plus qu'une
évolution c'est pas loin d'être une
révolution alors ceci dit elle se fera
en 10 ans puisque vous l'avez dit c'est
une réglementation évolutive d'ailleurs
intéressante sur ce plan là
puisque il y aura plusieurs seuils le
prochain seuil c'est 2025 le seuil 2022
a surtout impacté la construction de la
maison individuelle assez peu le
collectif le seuil 2025 va commencer à
impacter
fortement le la construction dans le
collectif 2028 et 2031 donc la fin de la
fin la réglementation définitive c'est
2031 c'est une réglementation assez pas
assez très exigeante notamment parce que
ça a été dit elle un petit elle intègre
la dimension carbone jusqu'à présent la
RT 2012 et ne mesurer que la performance
énergétique on introduit la dimension
carbone à tous les stades de l'évolution
du bâtiment c'est du stade de la
construction jusqu'à sa fin de vie c'est
ce qu'on appelle l'analyse du cycle de
vie
et ça veut dire qu'on intègre le stade
de la construction les émissions carbone
d'un bâtiment c'est 50% au moins 50% au
stade de la construction donc c'est ça
le point très très novateur de cette de
cette réglementation puisque avant on
intégrait pas du tout cette dimension et
on l'intègre avec une méthodologie
j'insiste au-dessus parce qu'elle a
donné lieu à beaucoup de débats qui
s'appelle la CV dynamique qui est une
une particularité française les Français
font pas les choses comme les autres
donc
en l'occurrence je pense c'est plutôt
pas mal mais ça a été très très contesté
aussi la CV dynamique ça signifie que
dans le calcul de l'analyse du cycle de
vie on va privilégier les matériaux qui
émettent leur carbone en fin de vie par
rapport au matériaux qui émettent leur
carbone en début de vie donc pour parler
très clairement l'aéron 2020 elle
favorise de manière très très claire les
matériaux bio sur C et le bois
puisque le bois émettra sont carbone
lorsqu'il sera détruit lorsqu'il sera
brûlé à la fin de son utilisation alors
que le béton ou l'acier vont émettre
évidemment leur carbone au moment de la
conception avec évidemment une dépense
d'énergie très importante donc sur ce
plan là c'est très clair ça veut dire
que en 2031 il n'y aura plus une maison
aujourd'hui en France qui sera
construite en béton les maisons seront
construites en bois ou en matériaux bio
sourcé ça peut être de la pierre par
ailleurs ça peut être autre chose du
béton de chanvre etc si on suit la
trajectoire j'y reviendrai actuelle
ça veut dire aussi que dans le collectif
aujourd'hui le bois représente environ
7%, on va passer à 40 50 voire plus un
promoteur qui était en train de réaliser
une
un immeuble Hero 2020 2031 donc il y a
déjà des promoteurs qui qui regarde cela
me disait que à moins de 80% de bois et
de matériaux bio sur C le bâtiment ne
passait pas
les seuils donc c'est pour vous donner
quand même le l'importance considérable
de l'évolution considérable de cette
affaire ce que je constate aujourd'hui
puisqu'elle est en quand même en vigueur
depuis 2022 elle s'appelle Hero 2020
mais qui a eu deux ans de retard c'est
l'aéro 2022 en réalité c'est que les
permis sont déposés
moi dans mon activité professionnelle
annexe
je constate qu'on voit commencer à
apparaître quand même des R20 2025 et
pas de manière comment dirais un peu à
mon étonnement d'ailleurs mais de
manière assez assez courantes c'est pas
c'est pas totalement exceptionnel ça
l'est encore mais c'est pas totalement
exceptionnel
donc le premier constat est plutôt celui
de d'une appropriation assez positive
par la filière alors ça a été dit le C2E
est chargé justement du suivi de l'aéro
2020 nous avons des rendez-vous avec
l'État
avant avant les les passages aux
différentes étapes donc premier
rendez-vous pour 2025 la DHP est en
train de se mettre en disposition pour
recueillir toute une un ensemble de
données et sur la base des données nous
verrons
ce comment il faut faire évoluer l'aéro
2020 à chacun des stades j'insiste à la
baisse ou à la hausse donc
voilà
mais mais honnêtement là pour le moment
moi j'ai plutôt le sentiment que les
choses sont en train de se mettre en
place sur le plan économique on avait eu
j'insiste là-dessus oui il y a un
surcoût
[Musique]
si j'ose dire sur le marché il y en aura
peut-être d'autres et peut-être que dans
le cadre de la DHP effectivement on
verra s'il faut trouver enfin on verra
la DHP vera parce que moi je m'occupe
pas de la DHP on demandera la DHP plutôt
de d'avoir évidemment des éléments
économiques qui permettent d'avancer là
dessus
j'ajoute une chose c'est qu'elle est
territorialisée comme le DPE vous avez
raison et ça c'est très important il y a
8 il y a 8 secteurs géographiques pour
l'aéro 2020 et il y en a 8 aussi pour le
DPE il faut bien comprendre qu'une
partie quand même du travail qui a été
fait sur l'aéronava s'est retrouvé dans
le DPE notamment toute la dimension
carbone c'est la même méthodologie aussi
de calcul enfin j'ai pas entrer dans le
détail mais en fait c'est quand même des
réglementations qui sont assez voisines
bon et c'est vrai qu'il y a pas il y a
pas de confort d'été dans le DPE il y en
a dans l'arro 20 d'ailleurs assez
intéressant mais il y a quand même la
prise en compte géographique climatique
et en fait c'est pas une réglementation
c'est 8 réglementations qu'on a un qui
varie assez sensiblement
pas mal de questions je vais essayer
dans l'ordre peut-être tout d'abord pour
répondre à vos à vos demandes concernant
la quote-part de la rénovation
énergétique dans les métiers du bâtiment
aujourd'hui donc en 2022 la part de
segment de la rénovation énergétique
donc tout type de bâtiments confondus
dans le bâtiment ressort à 14 % soit
23,5 milliards d'euros ça c'est nos
comptes de production et FFB donc c'est
à peu près le pourcentage si on
restreint au sol logements la part se
réduit à 10% seulement du total du
bâtiment donc ça représente 10% de notre
activité et toujours en 22 l'activité de
rénovation élastique a progressé de 1,9%
volume simplement donc plus 1,8 pour le
logement et plus de virgule 4 pour le
non-résidentiel voilà déjà les constats
pour bien replacer le débat en termes de
en termes de chiffres est-ce qu'on peut
dire malheureusement c'est que sur les
premiers trimestres 2023 par rapport au
premier trimestre 2022 on a une hausse
simplement de 1,3%, 1,6 pour le logement
et -05 que pour le non résidentiel voilà
pour replacer un petit peu un contexte
au niveau au niveau des chiffres ensuite
vous avez parlé je prépare pour les
différents points comme ce rapporteur à
aborder donc le confort d'été certes il
est pris en compte dans la R20 donc ce
qui est plutôt ce qui est plutôt une
bonne chose ça va arriver il est moins
dans la rénovation simplement parce
qu'il y a encore quelques voilà
aujourd'hui pour qu'il soit pris en
compte en rénovation il faut par exemple
qui est une climatisation déjà donc il y
a des je pense qu'il y a des curseurs à
remettre mais c'est une vraie c'est une
vraie solution sur lequel on doit on
doit travailler parce que confort d'été
quelque chose
segmentation qui était faite notamment
dans des écoles avec une du passif et du
salaire qui montre des vraiment des
différences importantes donc autant il
était pris en compte pour neuf autant
sur la rénovation je pense qu'il faut
qu'il soit plus plus
en compte ensuite sur la question du RGE
et votre votre interrogation que l'on
entend beaucoup est-ce que est-ce que
les entreprises du bâtiment sont prêtes
à répondre à ce nouveau marché
je dirais oui et d'autant plus avec ce
que le vous avez dit Madame la
satisatrice en introduction avec la
crise de logement qui nous attend qui
est déjà là nous on estime qu'on va
perdre 100 000 emplois dans les 200 qui
viennent d'une façon on voit très bien
on est sur -35% moins 40 % de
déclaration de permis de construire
comme l'a dit le président repos les
particuliers n'ont plus les moyens de
consolider des prêts c'est vrai qu'on
est revenu sur un sur de l'inflation
qu'on n'avait pas beaucoup connu on a
vous savez là votre augmentation
stabilité financière qui limite les taux
à 35% d'endettement et non pas le reste
à vivre et puis sur une durée de 25 ans
donc je dirais tout est là plus
enrichissement je suppose vraiment
d'accord avec vous ce caresse mais si
l'un de tes clodi on va vérifier pour
nous les Revin a vraiment monté monter
le coût de la construction alors
peut-être ça pas été pris en compte on a
beaucoup parlé de l'envoler des prix des
matériaux ces derniers mois il faut pas
oublier qu'il y a eu certes la scène
internationale avec des pénuries qui
sont là mais il faut également bien être
conscient que nos industriels se sont
engagés de manière massive sur le la
baisse la détermination de leur
industrie et ça globalement on paye ce
qui va arriver et donc ces retraits dans
le coût des matériaux aujourd'hui c'est
pour ça également que pour répondre ce
caresse je pense pas
qu'on aura 40 à 50 % mais ça on prend en
discuter 45 % de construction bois en
résine 2030 parce que il y a des progrès
très forts qui sont fait en ce moment le
béton on parle de on parle de béton vert
la scie on est en train de parler de
décarbulations donc voilà donc les
industriels sont pas restés ici ce matin
on était donc au lancement de du grand
plan de rénovation des des écoles et où
également nous a cité du des vitrages
avec 0 émissions des isolants etc donc
les industriels sont en train de faire
des progrès considérables et donc ça
rend chérit le coup ce qui fait
également qu'un autre avis ça sera le
bon matériau au bon endroit et je pense
qu'il faut bien que ça soit comme ça
doit le faire ce qu'ils n'ont pas ce que
cette Europe à 20 nous a permis et nous
sommes actifs en tant que président du
des professions il faut vraiment que nos
entreprises du bâtiment travaillent en
silo qu'on apprenne à travailler avec
des supports bois différents supports et
ça c'est quelque chose qui est très
important aussi bien en off qu'en
rénovation je vais pas être très long
ensuite vous allez parler du
monacompagnateur rénovation
nous on regrette on regrette que on
n'est pas laissé le choix aux
entreprises du bâtiment de pouvoir
accomplir cette mission parce que
simplement je pense que l'on connaît
très bien et mieux qui compte peut être
ce qu'il faut faire etc bon acte il n'en
demeure pas moins qu'on est inquiet sur
la capacité à avoir des un nombre de
rénovateurs énergétiques suffisant et
surtout qui est une vision globale du
geste du geste effectué donc ça on
regardera une fois que c'est parti et
concernant la même chose pour les pros
voilà je pense voilà quand on fait une
rénovation avec un architecte et autres
je pense qu'il y a peut-être pas besoin
de remettre des couches supplémentaires
qui peuvent coûter de l'argent alors que
globalement ça se fait globalement bien
voilà et sur votre lot de question
concernant alors oui je voulais dire
également pour reprendre sur les R20
c'est vrai que pour nous c'était un
séisme assez fort ce qu'on est passé que
2012 on a eu le on a eu le plus c'est
moins sur lequel on a travaillé en
expérimentation pendant donc qui
n'attaquerait pas qui n'intégrait pas
cette méthode dynamique donc se caresse
à parler mais pour nous on commençait à
s'habituer mais du jour au lendemain
c'est vrai qu'on ait une nouvelle
réglementation et donc il faut le temps
qu'on
assimile mais je dirais cette chose
faite nous ont pris le bâtiment de plus
en plus on est habitué maintenant voir
des fichiers des avoir le bilan carbone
de nos constructions beaucoup
d'entreprises également du bâtiment font
leur propre bilan carbone donc voilà je
dirais tout ça est en train d'être
intégré et concernant le RGEA mais je
pense qu'on en reparlera après pour nous
le le principal problème au RGE c'est
vraiment comment lutter de manière
efficience contre l'afro de RGE parce
que c'est vrai
on parle beaucoup de on parle beaucoup
de malfaçons mais globalement elles sont
pas faites par nos entreprises
vertueuses mais sont plutôt faites par
des pas des entreprises qui viennent
dans le bâtiment vous l'avez rappelé par
rapport à d'autres pays n'importe qui
peut demain faire du bâtiment on a
encore eu aujourd'hui
quelqu'un qui se fait massivement sur
énergétiques qui faisait avant du lavage
automobile et qui va de manière
importante sur ce marché là avec des
nouveaux acteurs puisque c'est plutôt il
y a de l'argent public donc c'est plutôt
des gens qui vont sur du marketing
direct etc donc ce que nos entreprises
ne savent pas vraiment faire allez
vendre leurs compétences et puis pour
terminer donc voilà sur un rappel quand
même il y a une petite baisse de RGE
mais je pense qu'il y a des liée plutôt
comme je disais en introduction sur les
coups de pouce c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui par exemple les gens qui
faisaient des combles étaient RGE les
menuiseries étaient RGE et quand il y a
des coups de pouce où on met plus
d'argent ou moins d'argent sur des airs
forcément on a des on a certaines
entreprises qui qui partent qui partent
qui partent du RGA simplement parce que
le marché n'était pas là mais encore une
fois il y a quand même plus de 500 000
aujourd'hui salariés dans les
entreprises RGA et avec ce qu'on nous
annonce ou que vous l'avez dit on est
tous en train on est tous en train
d'orienter de conseiller nos entreprises
à regarder de près la rénovation donc je
suis pas trop inquiet on entend beaucoup
dire ça nous on pense plutôt s'il y a
des fonds si le marché est là on pourra
répondre plutôt que dire le marché n'est
pas là parce que vous n'êtes pas en
rendez-vous voilà j'ai essayé de
répondre un petit peu un petit peu
rapidement Eric sur quelque chose
oui sur le fait qu'il est moins de RGE
c'est aussi dû au fait que les aides ont
été vraiment aménagées sur le ménage
modeste et très modeste mais si on
regarde les chiffres en province un
couple avec deux personnes dont deux
personnes vous voyez avec deux personnes
il n'est plus modeste à partir de 31000
euros et à partir de
43000 euros il est aisé
donc c'est pas c'est pas Bernard Arnault
non plus donc c'est pour ça que beaucoup
de ménages ont été exclus et qu'on a
beaucoup d'entreprises qui travaillaient
avec ce type de ménage qui n'ont plus
besoin du RJ car il a plus les aides
oui pour compléter et sur nos volumes
vous parlez de l'ordre de demander de
notre volume en rénovation mais pas que
transition énergétique rénovation de
tout court voilà pour pour nous en
bâtiment en entreprise artisanale du
bâtiment nous sommes à peu près à 60 et
70% dans la rénovation d'ailleurs vous
invitons le 24 mai au salon du monde où
on fait justement un événement à ce
sujet avec la présence de Monsieur Klein
sur comment les artisans vont relever le
défi de la transition énergétique donc
on est on est sur le sujet et rendez au
coeur du sujet juste redire aussi que
que le RGE comme il a été conçu avec sa
qualification et sa capacité à chaque
entreprise à avoir une qualification RG
ne fait pas la qualification de tous les
salariés et ça c'est un différent qu'on
a un peu que la Fédération française du
bâtiment puisque une entreprise de trois
salariés ou une entreprise de 10
salariés ou une entreprise de 5000
salariés à une qualification RGE donc ça
veut dire que on pas parce qu'on est un
jeu sur un collectif de 550 000
compétences dans les entreprises sur les
entreprises toutes qualifiées ou toutes
les compétences sont formées au moins et
ça ça nous pose problème et ça ça fait
une concurrence déloyale sur une TPE qui
a la même contrainte que l'entreprise de
100 personnes mais c'est pour ça que
nous on fera des propositions pour ne
pas enlever de la qualité au travail
bien au contraire mais être capable
d'auditer en fin de chantier et de
pouvoir vérifier que le travail bien la
hauteur de ce qui était demandé puisque
il faut quand même se rappeler que sur
la formation et ce qui est proposé dans
la réglementation de la réglementation
thermique c'est quand même que les
règles de l'art en fait quel que soit
les produits que l'on va poser qu'ils
évoluent qu'ils évoluent pas c'est la
c'est la règle de l'art qui sera qui
sera adéquate pour pouvoir être
performante et donc c'est vrai c'est
plutôt les interfaces entre les métiers
et comment on évite des des
incompétences ou des dysfonctionnements
entre les métiers que la mise en
application des règles de l'art qui sont
maintenant déjà intégrés dans les de
formation initiale des CAP et les BP les
bacs pro etc comprennent comprennent la
formation dite transition énergétique ce
qui veut dire que quand on quand on
rénove et quand on rénove un bâtiment en
isole en ventile on regarde la
production d'énergie mais on fait pas un
EPR mais il n'empêche que l'impact de la
et et le fait que
elle a aussi une prégnant sur sur la
rénovation on voit bien que il risque
d'arriver que le gaz soit totalement
défendu dans les mêmes dans la
rénovation demain alors que là le bilan
thermique il est plutôt défavorable au
gaz mais il n'empêche que on pousserait
au-delà de cette de cette compétence et
Revin la réalité économique du de la
rénovation et ça ça pose un problème
parce que laquelle la réalité de du
quotidien et d'animal d'un immeuble s'il
y a une chaudière qui doit être changé
le changement par une pompe à chaleur
comme elle est favorisée actuellement
elle me paraît totalement in par rapport
au confort au confort d'hiver d'été ok
mais partout par rapport au bilan
carbone donc on aura des difficultés il
faut je pense remettre un peu de bon
sens c'est pour ça que quand on parlait
de la mer il y a pas de problème sur la
elle est plutôt
de la valeur mais il faut qu'on ait
quand même aussi un recul et sur la
formation de nos collaborateurs dans nos
compétences parce que on ne fait pas
d'un chauffagiste demain un climaticien
dans la seconde qui suit et pour vous
dire le nombre de compétences qui qui
qui qu'on évalue nous il y a une étude
de la DARES qui donnait la création de
200 000 compétences et emplois pour
relever le défi de la transition
énergétique et nous nous capève qui
sommes spécifiquement sur la rénovation
en table sur cette ce potentiel là et on
travaille beaucoup notamment sur
l'apprentissage et nous avons à ce jour
en 2018 on nous avions 40 000 ans 30 ans
dans un dans le réseau de
l'apprentissage maintenant on a 100 000
apprentissage ça veut dire aussi qu'il y
a un temps de formation un temps de comp
et aussi je pense un temps
d'attractivité de nos métiers puisque
maintenant nos métiers ne sont pas que
des bâtisseurs ils sont aussi bâtisseurs
et sauveurs de planètes donc on peut
parler à la génération Z pour qu'il
rejoignent le débat de la transition
énergétique et rejoindre alors pour ma
part l'activité de l'artisanat du
bâtiment une une
entreprise à taille humaine et donc ça
veut dire aussi que il faut pas que ces
entreprises humaines soient exclues du
marché et ce qui se passe sur le RG
actuellement et plutôt dans ce sens là
et donc nous on est plutôt sur valoriser
la compétence à la fin du chantier et
éprouver le fait que le chantier est
bien adéquat avec les attendus que
mettre une qualification ou une
formation préalable qui vous permet
d'accéder à et on s'aperçoit que c'est
pas positif vous avez devant vous 560000
entreprises potentielles qui peuvent
relever le défi de la transition
énergétique des entreprises inscrites au
répertorié et de fait normalement
compétente voilà donc je pense qu'il
faudrait mettre plus d'argent et plus
sollicitations pour éveiller la
transition énergétique des ménages et
donc le reste à charge enfin en gros qui
est de moins de reste à charge je pense
que l'entreprise seront présentes pour
relever des filles en même temps qu'il
faudra ramener de plus en plus de jeunes
vers nos métiers leur montrer qu'ils
sont innovants qui sont biosourcés mais
pas que et qui peuvent répondre à la
transition énergétique donc à sauver sa
planète donc avoir un modèle économique
propre à l'artisan et à l'entreprise
mais également sauver la planète
le dispositif mon accompagnateur rénove
alors l'accompagnateur des pros je vais
laisser Henri il aime bien ce sujet qui
est touché pour nous parce qu'il nous
paraît à la traverse à travers deux
sujets qui peuvent être demain très vite
impactés donc je
sur le France rénov et les accompagnants
rénovent il y a de notre point de vue
sans doute trois points de vigilance le
premier point de vigilance on commence
juste le début de l'application et des
facto les ex ce réseau de l'ADEME et de
Lana
sont encore bien différents pour ne pas
dire totalement distinct encore et donc
si on veut que ça fonctionne il faut
vraiment qu'il y ait une mise en
cohérence une uniformisation des
différentes missions le deuxième point
de vigilance concerne la mission même de
l'accompagnateur Renov il doit être
efficace sur toute la partie
d'accompagnement des particuliers de
recherche de financement d'explications
etc mais ça a été dit tout à l'heure ne
pas aller sur le champ de la
préconisation de la conception voire
même du suivi de chantier parce que ça
ne sera pas évidemment dans son domaine
de compétence et puis le troisième point
de vigilance c'est que le dispositif va
dans une certaine mesure
déléguer des missions à des opérateurs
privés
il faut être particulièrement vigilant
et notamment on avait pas réussi à
l'obtenir au moment où il y avait des
discussions il est envisagé de pouvoir
déléguer à des délégataires notamment de
C2E et on considère que de ce point de
vue il y a vraiment un risque
de d'absence de neutralité sur qui
réalisera derrière et quels seront les
choix technologiques proposés
aux particuliers
le dispositif d'accompagnateur rénov
vous l'avez très bien dit tout à l'heure
c'est à peu près le le symétrique en
quelque sorte ça part d'une idée simple
c'est que on l'a dit un petit peu les
règles changent de manière continue le
dispositif m'imprimerait 9 RGE C2E c'est
extrêmement compliqué on a rajouté des
couches d'exigence les unes à la suite
des autres en général pour vouloir
lutter contre la fraude ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné et donc ce n'est pas en
rajoutant encore des exigences qu'on
arrivera à lutter contre la France
efficacement il faut le faire d'une
autre manière et c'est la proposition
faisait le président finalement est-ce
qu'il faut pas qu'on regarde
systématiquement ou très souvent en fin
de chantier
en abandonnant toutes ces exigences
d'ordre d'administratif l'accompagnateur
des pros c'est aider les entreprises de
petites tailles qui font un ou deux
chantiers par an non pas parce qu'elles
ne sont pas compétentes mais parce que
le marché n'en demande pas plus à les
aider à monter un dossier
à répondre aux exigences administratives
à respecter les timings et qui sont
demandés de pouvoir fonctionner du côté
de ma prime rénov des certificats
d'économie d'énergie toute cette partie
qui est extrêmement compliquée pour une
entreprise alors qu'elle est compétente
dans son métier donc c'était ça ce qu'on
essaye de faire et on souhaiterait que
ça puisse généraliser assez vite parce
que c'est le moyen pour nous d'augmenter
le nombre d'entreprises RGE 96% des
entreprises du secteur du bâtiment ont
moins de 10 salariés donc on peut dire
que 96% des entreprises ne comprennent
pas le dispositif ont du mal avec le
dispositif du fait de ces exigences
qu'on a empilées les unes à la suite des
autres
et qui encore une fois ne servent pas
l'objectif qu'on s'est donné puisque
c'est vous vous l'avez dit à juste titre
on continue à avoir des opportunistes
des des entreprises qui viennent sur le
marché dès qu'il y ait un coup de pouce
on voit arriver une entreprise qui font
de l'isolation à 1 euro puis après elles
se mettent à la pack à 1 € et puis
aujourd'hui elles se mettent sur la
rénovation globale en euros
poêle à bois la fraude une des fraudes
ou une partie de la fraude de Lana c'est
les poêle à bois dans les immeubles
haussmanniens à Paris c'est comme ça
qu'ils se sont aperçus alors pourquoi
parce que c'est là où le niveau d'aide
était plus important donc le fraudeur il
s'est dit ben je vais créer des faux
chantiers avec des faux appartements
voilà donc et pourtant on a des
exigences qui sont extrêmement fortes et
qui
bloquent les initiatives des entreprises
vertueuses
le fraudeur il arrive toujours à
s'adapter
est-ce que juste pour compléter les
propos Jackson repousse que je rejoins
c'est qu'aujourd'hui je crois que vous
avez vous avez reçu les oreilles de
qualification
aujourd'hui dans un dossier RGE on doit
mettre 5 chantiers donc c'est
complètement aberrant qu'une entreprise
quelle que par rapport au nombre de
chantiers qu'elle réalise elle doit
avoir des elle doit être le nombre de
chantiers contrôlés doivent être
doivent être par rapport au nombre de
chantiers que réalisent entreprises ça
c'est le premier point et le deuxième
point il faut bien savoir qu'aujourd'hui
une entreprise peut contractualiser avec
une âme imprimerie 9 sans être rjeuner
donc ça c'est quand même complètement
fou aujourd'hui il suffit d'avoir des
sous-traitants derrière et des
entreprises donc dont on parlait elles
sont pas faim des terres pour les
contractualiser et pour bénéficier de ma
prime rénote donc voilà c'était pour
abonder un peu sur ces sur ses propos et
en tous les cas en tous les cas il faut
voilà et c'est pour ça malheureusement
et bien sûr il faut pas que il faut
également qu'il y ait des contrôles
aléatoires faut pas que ce soit les sacs
les cinq chantiers 5 chantiers sur des
centaines de réalisés qui sont
exemplaires il faut vraiment qu'on
puisse doter de moyens et d'aller faire
des contrôles aléatoires et pour s'en en
reparlera après il faut vraiment qu'il y
en rapprochement des fichiers des
fichiers de manière à les voir des
chantiers complètement aléatoires on va
se jeter juste un complément juste aussi
pour compléter pour bien que vous prenez
conscience de pour la sécurité
électrique qui existe en France pour toi
pour avoir accès à de l'électricité un
point de livraison il existe le consuel
vous avez pas besoin d'être qualifié
pour faire l'installation consuel si
demain moi j'en fais qu'une parent il
viendra me vérifier si j'en fais 12 par
an il viendra aléatoirement et il livre
250 000 points de livraison par an
sur un système d'audit a postériori sans
qualification et on le fait pour la
sécurité donc c'est pour la sécurité
individuelle de chaque personne et on le
fait aussi pour le gaz mais pour
l'argent public pour éviter la fraude on
fait bien pire qu'il n'empêche pas la
fraude donc et donc on sort des
entreprises qui pourraient répondre à la
commande nous sommes nous paraît de bon
sens
une précision par rapport à ce que
est-ce que vous dites et peut-être du
coup plutôt pour la pour la cape mais ce
que ce que vous préconisez vraiment en
fait c'est c'est l'abandon du RGE enfin
en tout cas d'une labellisation et
plutôt d'aller vers une un contrôle en
fin de chantier quoi et de se dire à
partir du moment où on a une entreprise
qui réalise les travaux ce qui compte
c'est que on arrive au résultat et voilà
ça c'est ça enfin c'est ce que c'est ce
que vous dites je crois qu'on peut faire
les deux je veux dire que l'entreprise
qui a envie d'être dans le marché du RGE
et qui a envie de démontrer à son client
qu'il a voulu un avantage qu'il a déjà
réfléchi et qui me fait de son métier du
RGE je pense pas je pense que ces gens
là il faut les garder avec une
qualification par contre le coup par
coup le chantier qui n'effet qu'une fois
sur une chaudière parce que je vais pas
faire 10 chaudières à granulés et mais
que je peux faire en compétence il faut
pas l'interdire voilà donc je pense
qu'il faut pas poser les deux je pense
qu'il faut continuer à garder on a je
crois une soixantaine de mille
entreprises de RGE également
il y a de moins en moins chaque année
mais on a quand même 70000 donc il faut
quand même peut-être ces gens-là qui ont
décidé depuis le début de de passer des
des formations avec fibat etc et après
on pourrait se servir en plus de
l'argent des C2E pour faire ces audits
l'argent de ces deux autres pourrait
permettre à prendre une partie de
l'audit en charge parce qu'il faudrait
quand même des auditeurs de qualité pour
pouvoir relever le défi et du coup
peut-être une question complémentaire du
coup sur le
sur le
sur le survie sur
le sur le RGE
pour vous dans son application est-ce
que ça a vraiment fait monter en
capacité en termes de
qualité en tout cas les entreprises
enfin ce que vous pensez que les
entreprises qui sont rentrées dans ce
cycle là du coup sont montés en
compétence quoi en gros elles ont eu au
moins déjà l'effort de se former sur les
formations dites fibat il y en a eu je
sais plus le nombre en tête mais 200300
000 formations fibat je crois 1 300000
de formation ce qui veut dire que
l'entreprise qui était compétente dans
son métier elle a fait l'effort de
regarder les efforts qu'elle devait
faire en monter en compétences pour
travailler sur la transition énergétique
dont je trouve que c'est plutôt très
louable et puis de toute façon d'avoir
un focus d'avoir
un phare allumé là-dessus c'est toujours
intéressant et nous c'est pour ça que on
porte nos à nos adhérents tout a
démarche
[Musique]
ce qui a contribué à monter aussi en
compétences c'est des programmes dont on
parle sans doute assez peu mais le
programme rage le programme pack le
programme profil qui ont contribué à
réécrire une partie des règles de l'art
de faire des recommandations des
checklists des points de contrôle pour
les entreprises qui ces éléments là sont
de plus en plus utilisés et contribuent
évidemment à mieux travailler et à mieux
travailler ensemble et en fait des autos
diagnostic à la fin du chantier pour
savoir si la performance est bien
atteinte et c'est des travaux qui sont
faits avec profits qui sont très
intéressants pour monter en compétences
pour nos artisans et c'est à mon sens la
bonne démarche
peut-être un argument supplémentaire ce
qu'il faut savoir également c'est
qu'avec la refonte du RGE lorsqu'on est
en audit sur chantier lorsqu'on a un
écart on est plus enfin les suspicions
sont plus dans un rôle de
d'accompagnateur pour éviter de les
refaire etc donc je pense que quand même
ces audits ont du bon c'est ce qu'on
voit pas vraiment comme une censure mais
voilà sur tel et chantée il y a des
écarts on a des écarts qui peuvent être
mineurs donc ça me paraît = ils ont
également un rôle pédagogique qui est
reconnu que l'on n'avait pas qu'on
n'avait pas
au préalable et puis moi je rincite on
n'est pas bon d'accord mais étant donné
que ce que disons préalable que
n'importe quel entreprise aujourd'hui
accepte de bâtiments sans aucune
formation je pense c'est quand même
parler qualifications qu'on peut avoir
un minimum de formation et reconnaître
la confiance d'entreprise même si je
rejoins tous les efforts qu'on a fait
avec les avec les formations les fibates
et programmera et tous les guides que
nous unons de métiers font de manière
sur les entreprises une espèce de
check-list et des contrôles et puis les
remontées également des qualifications
ça permet également aux entreprises
d'avoir des points de vigilance
demander aussi il y a quelques années ça
n'a pas encore été mis en place c'est
que pour les audits ils ne sont pas
faits sur la base des chantiers déclarés
par les entreprises mais sur la base des
retours de chantier qu'on avait par Lana
ou par les obliger ça avait été discuté
avec les pouvoirs publics il y a
toujours pas mis en place mais c'est
quelque chose qui nous semble vraiment
important
un rapprochement des dc2e et RGE parce
qu'on a des audits différenciés selon
qu'on soit ce qui est et on a créé un
produit à côté profil qui fait un audit
encore enfin qui réunit les deux donc on
a quand même et on a aussi je pense la
nécessité et ça fait longtemps qu'on
nous le dit il y a eu un rapport qui a
été fait en ce sens par la DPP de
simplification et de rapprochement des
signes
depuis deux ans les organismes de
qualification
[Musique]
la belle commun ou
avec le souhait aussi de s'assurer de
qui c'est bien le chantier parce qu'il y
a la personne qui traite le marché qui
n'est pas forcément votre bien vérifier
que celui qui le fait à la fin est bien
Hergé
alors on parle beaucoup dans la
rénovation par geste et bien sûr les
rénovations globales performantes même
si on est tous bien évidemment convaincu
en tout cas qu'il faut aller vers plus
des rénovations globales performantes
mais pour autant considérer aussi que
cette rénovation par geste elle a le
mérite quand même de pouvoir faire en
sorte que on s'approprie et qu'on
commence à après c'est pas toujours
évident d'arriver à apporter jusqu'au
bout une rénovation globale performante
mais cette rénovation par geste il faut
quand même aujourd'hui encore la
maintenir
nous enfin il était souvent et on ne
peut pas opposer les deux puisque bien
évidemment qu'une rénovation globale
elle est plus vertueuse et elle marche à
tous les coups donc on ne peut pas être
contre et puis on serait un peu un peu
stupide ou artisans que de vous dire que
plus de travail peut nous plairait pas
donc c'est pas c'est pas le but donc
mais la réalité du chantier en fait la
réalité de votre quotidien en fait de
vous particulier c'est que si on doit
vous rénover une
un site habité et et
jamais vous rentrez dans la démarche
alors que nous on préfère avoir des
vrais diagnostics de base qui fasse un
audit détail initial permettant
d'arriver à un global en faisant tous
les gestes qu'il faut et vous donner la
capacité de dire peut-être ces années je
fais ce geste là dans deux ans j'en
forêt un autre dans trois ans encore un
autre et puis dans cinq ans je serai
arrivé au niveau B qui fait que mon mon
mon
habitation mon logement permet de
valoriser d'être valorisé il y a ça qui
nous paraît important et donc ce
parcours de rénovation qui nous paraît
essentiel mais qu'il faut écrire il faut
bien avoir un état initial factuel en
disant ben je sais que il me faudra tant
de gestes pour y arriver pour améliorer
au moins de 30 40% ce qui était
l'objectif n'est pas trop thermique mais
il faudra aussi inévitablement que que
le secteur bancaire
avec l'État j'imagine parce que sans
l'état ça me paraît impossible Vienne
proposer un produit financier
intéressant je prends souvent comme
exemple le modèle automobile mais le
secteur automobile a créé des parties
financières qui peuvent permettre en
trois clics d'acheter la voiture hybride
ou pas hybride de sortir du garage en
trois clics avec ça prend deux secondes
si vous voulez rénover vous sur
l'invasion dit globale chez vous je vous
conseille de prendre du temps pour aller
voir votre banquier arriver à avoir un
prêt à 50 cent mille euros pour
valoriser votre maison alors que la
véhicule caractéristiques du conseil
général déjà perdu 30%, le normalement
votre votre logement devrait lui au
contraire prendre de la plus-value alors
au ventre donc il y a deux éléments
forts qu'il faut pas opposer le Global
au geste parce que souvent le premier
geste de la rénovation c'est la panne
quand on fait face à une panne et ben on
change l'objet qui est qui est foutu par
un objet qui est vertueux et qui
commence le premier geste et de ce fait
vous pouvez rencontrer et dire si demain
vous ventilez si demain vous isolez
peut-être vous gagnerez les 30 à 40% qui
vous faut pour pour la performance
énergétique et votre avis sur le prix
avance mutation
je voulais revenir sur la rénovation
performante parce que c'est quand même
un sujet je pense à ces central
l'objectif quand même c'est d'être BBC
le porter le parc
immobilier français d'ailleurs
résidentiel et tertiaire pas oublier le
tertiaire il y a eu deux critères il y a
eu toute une série aussi de
d'initiatives qui ont été prises à
l'aéro 20 tertiaire
c'est de le porter au niveau BBC en 2050
bon
comment y parvenir
je pense que je d'abord pour le Conseil
l'idée quand on a délibéré de ces
questions
l'idée de maintenir une
rénovation par geste a été évidemment
été adoptée maintenant ce qui est
important à mon avis c'est que cela
s'insère dans un parcours qui permette à
terme d'atteindre l'objectif BBC en 2050
et donc le sujet me semble-t-il c'est
pas d'opposé
rénovation performante et rénovation par
geste mais d'avoir une vision quand même
globale de la rénovation vous allez
perdre dès le départ
et c'est là bon il y a le dispositif
accompagnateur etc je pense qu'il y a un
gros travail là
pour pas que de l'argent à la fois
public et privé soient perdue parce que
on sait très bien qu'un certain nombre
d'une rénovation par geste ne
permettront jamais d'arriver à une
rénovation performante donc le sujet il
est vraiment d'essayer de profiler les
choses de telle sorte qu'on arrive quand
même à tenir cet objectif cet objectif
j'attire votre attention là-dessus il
est extrêmement ambitieux puisque il
reviendrait à
rénover sur le plan énergétique 20
millions de logements privés c'est ça
l'objectif 20 millions de logements
privés à rénover le raisonnement que je
tiens c'est un raisonnement qui a été
tenu par le CGED
ça veut dire 11 millions de maisons
individuelles
rénovation performante sur 11 millions
de maisons-individuelles disons à 50000
euros 50000 euros en moyenne c'est pas
beaucoup voilà donc ça fait 550
milliards
vous ajoutez
9 millions de logements collectifs
à 20 000 euros donc là non plus c'est
pas beaucoup ça fait 180 milliards donc
le coût total c'est 730 milliards
c'est-à-dire 27 milliards par an
jusqu'en 2050 20 milliards par an
jusqu'en 2060 15 milliards par an
jusqu'en 2070 donc ça vous donne je
pense le
l'importance de l'effort
si on se tient encore une fois
l'objectif qui est dans la SNBC
aujourd'hui qui sera j'imagine confirmé
d'ailleurs parce qu'elle est en révision
prochainement bon donc voilà
l'importance de l'effort l'importance de
l'effort aussi financier voilà
l'État peut beaucoup de choses mais
est-ce qu'il peut
consacrer plus d'un point de PIB à la
rénovation thermique je n'en sais rien
si j'ai une petite idée quand même donc
ça veut dire quand même que pour parler
clairement il y a aussi un gros travail
à faire pour trouver des investissements
pour trouver un modèle économique moi
j'insiste au dessus pour ça que je suis
assez je vous le dis sincèrement je suis
assez opposé à l'idée de service public
parce que l'idée de service public c'est
quand même
parce que d'abord dans le secteur il y a
beaucoup de choses qui il y a pas grand
chose qui est public à part l'argent
le reste c'est quand même des acteurs
privés c'est pas du tout ils ont
vêtements
légitimes mais mais donc service public
je pense que ça ça
contribue quand même à des
responsabiliser
les gens et quand on parle de fraude il
y a aussi ça derrière c'est parce que la
fraude évidemment quand vous vous ne
payez pas quelque chose vous regardez
pas toujours ce que vous achetez je suis
désolé mais je pourrais prendre le Pinel
c'est exactement la même chose bon tu
pourras en parler des heures donc donc
voilà donc ça des responsabilise bon ça
c'est le premier sujet le deuxième sujet
c'est le modèle économique modèle
économique vous voyez bien que enfin je
crois pas que l'État même si l'État peut
être doit augmenter ça après c'est un
débat d'ailleurs qui m'appartient pas
mais j'ai vu qu'il y a des amendements
qui sont adoptés ici ou là mais il faut
trouver un modèle économique et le
modèle économique pour moi il passe je
vous le dis alors très sincèrement par
un signal prix
ça veut dire qu'il faut reprendre quand
même le sujet de la taxe carbone d'une
manière ou d'une autre si vous voulez
avoir des investisseurs qui viennent
dans sur ce secteur il faut leur dire ça
coûtera tant à tel moment et là aussi il
faudra que on soit capable de l'autre
sinon il reviendront pas
les investisseurs particuliers c'est
pareil aujourd'hui ils ont beaucoup de
mal même si le coût de l'énergie a
beaucoup augmenté donc évidemment les
choses changent quand même mais enfin
les investisseurs particuliers ont
beaucoup de mal à trouver un retour sur
investissement
[Musique]
merci oui donc je vous rejoins bien sûr
je trouvais le modèle économique je
voulais revenir quand même sur le sur
les rénovation globale donc certes c'est
ce qu'il faut il faut aller vers le BBC
mais faisons attention à ne pas arrêter
le geste brutalement parce que ça aura
deux conséquences la première c'est
qu'on a une multitude d'entreprises qui
vont se retirer du RGA donc on aura
moins de personnes je suis tellement
dire qu'une rénovation globale pour un
ménage chez intrusif donc il faut
vraiment et on plaide vraiment pour
avoir une espèce de passeport c'est à
dire qu'on soit pas obligé de faire
global tout de suite mais des gestes
successifs qui vont tendre vers la
version globale donc je pense que ça
c'est c'est relativement important et
puis quand même quelques chiffres pour
illustrer de ce dont on parle on a
présent on a fait 500 simulations à la
FFB l'isation des murs en un geste fait
gagner de l'ordre de 30% de consommation
d'énergie donc une multitude de gestes
c'est quand même important c'est 30%
juste sur cela et puis pareil le
changement une pompe à chaleur
et hybride permettant un grand un gain
tout de suite en moyenne de 45% par
rapport à notre de chauffage donc déjà
rien qu'avec ces monogestes on sort déjà
toutes les passoires FSG donc il est
important certes il fallait évaluation
globale mais il faut vraiment continuer
à accompagner et certes il faut aller où
vous dites mais si on avait un tout de
suite globale d'abord les ménages comme
les dits seraient pas financier on n'a
pas le modèle économique et ça serait
dramatique
pour vous parce qu'on a vu les
évolutions donc on avait des crédits
d'impôts puis on est passé maintenant
aux aides de ma prime rénove quel est
votre appréciation du sujet par rapport
à quand il y avait des crédits d'impôts
et maintenant le dispositif ma prime
rénov
je pense un petit peu ce que l'on a dit
tout à l'heure c'est qu'on est passé
où était plutôt ciblé des ménages non
très modestes qui avaient des crédits
d'impôts de la défiscalisation si on a
vu des fenêtres des choses comme ça à
100% très modeste et modeste avec les
chiffres dont vous a rappelé on pense
qu'il y a d'autres il y a d'autres
solutions qui pourraient être mis en
place par exemple lors d'une revente
d'inciter les gens à faire des travaux
enfin ils pourraient avoir d'autres
choses je pense on est passé de loin à
l'autre et je pense qu'on pourrait
essayer d'avoir des dispositifs
ingénieux pour mixer les deux et
notamment lorsqu'il y a c'est vrai que
lorsqu'il y a des revend sur des droits
de mutation des choses comme ça on
pourra inciter les personnes qui
achètent à faire des travaux je pense
que c'est comme dans tout il fait il
faut essayer de faire un bon un bon
modèle entre les deux
alors est-ce que parmi nos collègues qui
assistent à l'audition et qui auraient
des interventions oui Sabine Draxler
merci madame la Présidente alors
j'aimerais savoir si vous estimez que
les spécificités du bâti patrimonial
sont suffisamment prises en compte
actuellement dans les chantiers de
rénovation énergétique s'il est
technique d'isolation qui sont utilisées
actuellement vous paraissent
suffisamment respectueux des qualités
architecturales et notamment des
spécificités hygrothermiques de ce de ce
type de bâti je pense aux maisons à
pente bois ou maison en pierre et est-ce
que vous pensez que les propriétaires et
également les artisans sont suffisamment
informés des techniques et des matériaux
spécifiques à ce type de bâti
qui veut répondre
bien répondre sur les artisans parce
qu'après je vais être obligé de vous
quitter c'est pas parce que le sujet
m'intéresse pas mais je dois écouter
l'agenda de madame la Première ministre
donc je dois vous quitter
sur l'artisan est-ce qu'il est
suffisamment qualifié ou pas qualifié
sur les nouvelles techniques ça c'est
l'artisan il
crée son entreprise avec un diplôme puis
tout au long de sa vie il continue à se
former je vous garantis parce qu'avec
nos fabricants et industriels on est
tout le temps en formation alors on a un
niveau technique de base de qualité me
semble-t-il et souvent on a passé de
fierté de à le dire mais je trouve que
on devrait le dire plus souvent et après
on continue tout au long de la vie
puisque vous savez quand vous avez un
cap 20 ans après des techniques de pause
et les matériaux évoluent ils n'ont
cessé d'évoluer et donc on aura du bio
sur C et chaque fois c'est c'est notre
rôle aussi en tant qu'organisation
patronale c'est de que de dire à nos
artisans adhérents de continuer à aller
voir les formations les compétences qui
évoluent les méthodes de poste qui
continuent à évoluer et en fait si le
marché est bien présent c'est le marché
est bien présent l'artisan se forme sans
problème si vous voulez le former un
marché qui ne décolle pas vous avez pour
vous je peux vous le dire en tant que
président d'une confédération vous avez
des artisans qui vient vous le reprocher
après en disant vous nous avez dit de
faire du RGE vous nous avez dit de nous
former il n'y a pas de marché et on
s'est fait beaucoup beaucoup dans nos
assemblées générales la discussion a été
beaucoup là-dessus on a en un camion où
il y a 10 autocollants de qualification
ça me sert à rien donc par contre si le
marché est bien présent ici il faut sur
le patrimoine arriver à avoir des
techniques bien spécifiques souvent en
plus dans des territoires c'est souvent
des territoires vous avez les artisans
du coin qui vont se former à la
technique qui va bien aller pour que le
client soit satisfait parce que
l'artisan vertueux il veut faire 30 ans
dans le même endroit donc logiquement la
contreperformance c'est pour lui source
de non travaux dans l'avenir
sur ce point là si je peux rajouter nos
entreprises elles sont passionnées par
la technique et donc elles sont
éventuées entrepreneurs moyennes donc
tout ce qui est nouveau elles ont envie
de se mettre dessus d'apprendre etc par
contre je rejoins il faut qu'il y a un
marché en face c'est ça donc mais si le
marché est là je veux dire c'est dans
nos chaînes c'est dans nos gènes de
savoir ce qui va se passer quels sont
les évolutions et organisations
professionnelle on est là pour ça pour
les accompagner et je peux vous dire
qu'on le fait régulièrement
régulièrement moi dans tous les métiers
on diffusé énormément on fait des guides
on a des projets recherchés
développement sur des mails sur des
nouveaux matériaux donc je veux dire oui
oui ils sont présents et c'est vrai
qu'ils nous plutôt quelques fois de dire
vous nous parlez ça vous paraître ça
mais est-ce que le marché est au
rendez-vous mais je dirais c'est dans
l'organe de comprendre ce qui se fait
c'est vraiment dans leur gêne et de voir
un peu les évolutions techniques
majeures donc par rapport à d'autres
secteurs d'activité je suis pas très
inquiet sur ce sujet là sur l'autre
question Eric peut-être répondre sur le
sur le bâti
je peux dire un mot sur le patrimoine
quand bon la rénovation énergétique en
général elle se fait le plus efficace
c'est de les faire par l'extérieur donc
c'est comme ça en général que les choses
se font donc effectivement ça suppose un
bâti en général assez récent quand même
et ça se fait pas sur le bâtiment ancien
sur le bâti ancien c'est une rénovation
par l'intérieur c'est des choses qu'on
sait faire donc c'est
possible ça coûte plus cher
je crois aussi qu'on perd un peu en
mètre carré
et en performance mais la performance
est calibrée elle est moins moins
exigeante donc de ce point de vue là il
y a quand même une prise en compte dans
la réglementation d'une performance
moins exigeante que pour le bâti le plus
récent ça me permet de dire un mot sur
le DPE quand même parce que je
bon le DPE d'abord c'est une
réglementation je vous l'ai dit qui qui
était un petit peu
dans la continuité de l'aéronava ceci
dit il a été quand même
fait très très rapidement beaucoup plus
rapidement que l'aéro 20
puisque l'aéro 2020 ça a été dit avait
quand même même si la méthodologie a pas
toujours pas été forcément la même mais
enfin il y avait eu quand même une phase
de d'expérimentation de plus de deux ans
avec le dispositif le plus c'est moins
bon donc là ça a été très rapide
peut-être trop je n'en sais rien parce
qu'il y avait une contrainte de temps et
compris qui était d'ailleurs dans la loi
au passage c'est-à-dire que c'était la
loi qui avait bon donc l'administration
là la accepté vous avez vu que ça a
donné lieu quand même des petits
problèmes au départ un petit cafouillage
aujourd'hui
l'essentiel a été réglé néanmoins et ça
je veux quand même le dire ici parce que
ça serait c'est ce que ce qui se dit au
sein du csc2e donc c'est pas moi qui qui
le dis néanmoins on suggère quand même
de continuer à travailler sur le plan
technique sur le DPE
le DPE a quand même semble-t-il alors je
suis pas je suis pas ingénieur je suis
pas technicien tout ça est très complexe
mais quand même par exemple il pénalise
semble-t-il de manière un peu excessive
les petites surfaces
pour des raisons que je rentrais pas
dans le détail mais bon donc ça c'est un
sujet qui est quand même posé
l'autre problème du DPE c'est que c'est
un DPE par logement c'est à dire c'est
un problème aussi qu'on a avec l'aérone
puisque nous on avait souhaité que
l'aéron 2020 vaille DPE c'est à dire que
quand vous avez construit un immeuble
hérovins par exemple 2031 vous puissiez
avoir automatiquement un DPE ça
paraissait logique non ça n'a pas été
possible donc il y aura quand vous aurez
construit votre bâtiment il y aura aussi
un DPE qui sera bon c'est à dire que
c'était peut-être un peu super
fatigatoire mais pourquoi parce que le
DPE est lié à chaque logement et chaque
logement et est une individualité si
j'ose dire qui qui est très différent
qui peut être très différente dans un
même immeuble
la personne qui est placée au milieu de
l'immeuble etc qui est chauffé par ses
voisins etc il aura bon si c'est un
grand une grande surface on considère
qu'il y a moins de consommation de de
d'eau chaude de sanitaire etc donc le
DPE sera plus favorable
donc voilà il faut bien reconnaître que
c'est quand même pas une source de de
d'industrialisation si j'ose dire
surtout que ça vous le connaissez
j'imagine que le gouvernement en train
d'y travailler et le problème des
copropriétés puisque évidemment celui
qui a un DPE convenable il a aucun
intérêt à faire des travaux alors que
celui qui a un EPE qui est en dessous et
qui est figé il se retrouve avec une
passoire thermique bon donc vraiment il
y a un sujet quand même sur le
l'autre point c'est que quand vous
faites des travaux vous n'avez pas de
garantie sur le DPE c'est quand même un
sujet je parlais tout à l'heure des
investisseurs
donc vous investissez vous avez quand
même un retour sur investissement qui
est quand même souvent très éloigné mais
en plus vous n'avez pas la garantie de
changer de classe
à l'issue des travaux
c'est quand même compliqué je veux dire
parce que il faut
il y a pas c'est pas une science exacte
manifestement donc
voilà moi je pense qu'il faudrait
peut-être aussi sécuriser un peu plus
les choses sur ce plan là je sais pas
comment ce peut être une réflexion à
avoir avec les les
techniciens qui qui travaillent
là-dessus mais il y a quand même
régulièrement au sein de notre
conseil
des réserves et des questions sur le DPE
enfin sur le BBC j'avais vu qu'il y
avait une je reviens là-dessus quand
même sur il y avait une question dans
votre questionnaire puisqu'on a donné un
avis sur le run BBC rénovation
effectivement on a retiré le
l'interdiction du chauffage au gaz de
chauffage et de chaufferie au gaz pour
une raison très simple donc je donne la
réponse parce que j'ai vu le
questionnaire c'est que c'était
totalement superfétatoire c'est à dire
que les la performance baisser
rénovation implique le gaz ne passe plus
ça veut pas dire qu'il y a pas un débat
sur le gaz et là je vais aussi m'en
faire écho monsieur repon là un peu dit
il y a quand même un vrai débat sur le
gaz il y a eu un débat au moment de
l'aéro 2020 beaucoup d'organisations au
sein du CSC de cc2e souhaité qu'on
puisse garder des systèmes hybrides
c'est-à-dire Pâques gaz
pourquoi d'abord parce que la Pâques
c'est pas la panacée non plus
universelle c'est à dire que la PAC sur
le plan technique a aussi certaines
limites notamment évidemment quand il
fait très froid
la PAC par ailleurs fait du bruit aussi
il y a un problème d'insertion donc dans
et à l'époque je veux dire que l'État
nous avait dit on interdit le gaz dans
la construction ce qu'elle a l'air en
fait à partir de 2025 interdira
l'interdit d'ores et déjà dans la maison
individuelle et l'interdira à partir de
2025 et on nous avait dit on réserve le
gaz à la rénovation sauf qu'aujourd'hui
ce qu'on est en train de voir c'est que
le gaz est en train d'être sorti de la
rénovation et quand même avec un une
interrogation sur la mixité de l'énergie
sur la capacité de tout passer en
électrique la capacité énergétique
ça peut être une question parce que il
n'y a pas que le problème il y a le
problème évidemment de gaz à effet de
serre mais il y a aussi le problème de
la sécurité énergétique et de la
souveraineté énergétique bon nous on a
enfin
bon et par ailleurs il y a aussi la
possibilité là c'est ce que disent quand
même aussi la filière gaz c'est que il y
a le développement du gaz propre bon
voilà donc l'exclure complètement alors
qu'on a en plus les réseaux parce qu'on
a les réseaux etc c'est ce privé des
réseaux c'est à dire dans les villes les
autres gaz il existe bon donc est-ce que
c'est bien raisonnable enfin je pose la
question je sais que beaucoup de
d'organisation au sein du cc2e ce sont
interrogés ce sont interrogés là-dessus
maintenant ce que je crois comprendre
aussi c'est qu'au niveau européen
puisque vous avez parlé évidemment ce
sera le ça sera la grande maintenant que
le socle réglementaire est posé est-ce
qu'il va devoir évoluer par rapport à ce
qui va être décidé au niveau européen au
niveau européen il y a manifestement une
volonté d'interdire purement et
simplement tous les les toutes les les
énergies carbonées
qu'elles soient gaz etc etc voilà
mais à ce jour il n'y a pas de solution
technique dans un certain nombre de
situations et notamment en immeuble
collectif chauffage individuel il n'y a
pas de solution technique donc toutes
les raisons que vous avez évoquées sont
exactes mais on n'a pas de solution à
proposer à un particulier si le gaz est
interdit
aujourd'hui en plus la aujourd'hui le
choix qui est fait c'est la Pâque c'est
le réseau de chaleur alors le réseau de
chaleur
maintenant il y a une obligation un
raccordement qui a été qui a été décidé
donc c'est à dire que aujourd'hui si
vous construisez avec un réseau de
chaleur vous n'avez pas le choix vous
êtes obligé de prendre le réseau de
chaleur je trouve d'ailleurs tout ça
plutôt positif mais il faut quand même
savoir que les trois quarts des réseaux
de chaleur d'origine ne sont pas des
carbonées donc il y a un effort
considérable à faire sur la
décarbonation des réseaux de chaleur bon
mais d'ailleurs je pense que c'est un
choix qui va être aussi très encouragé
au niveau au niveau européen
il y a un autre point quand même qu'il
faut avoir aussi en tête sur le sur la
PAC c'est que c'est vraiment pas une
technologie française
ça vient de Chine tout vient de Chine
alors que dans le chauffage notamment
gaz il y a une excellence française il y
a des industriels je connais
quelques-uns
à côté vous me les connaissez mieux que
moi qui sont très très bons qui sont
très performants bon donc il faut le
savoir aussi un enjeu industriel
ce que je voulais rajouter sur le gaz
c'est ce qu'on avait ce qu'on avait
évoqué c'est que ce qu'il faut
s'attendre à niveau B mais je pense
qu'il faut il faut pas rester il faut
restreindre aucune technologie on sait
également qu'il y a des il y a des
innovations qui peuvent être fait sur le
biofut ou sur le biogaz donc sur du gaz
vert et là en fait si on avait
complètement interdit de faire le gars
déjà on n'a pas de remplacement une en
plus on coupe les longs sur tout les
technologies souvent françaises et qui à
mon avis font de gros progrès donc
encore une fois c'est comme les
matériaux le bon produit au bon endroit
et arrêter de faire des des va-et-vient
c'est tout électrique c'est tout donc je
pense que c'est important de ne pas
couper les longs l'objectif c'est
atteindre le niveau B et les industriels
et nous qui mettons en oeuvre imaginatif
pour pas le faire
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner un
petit mot sur les C2 est-ce que vous
pensez aujourd'hui de de ce dispositif
de son fonctionnement comment est-ce
qu'il pourrait évoluer parce que là
aussi
c'est quand même pas très très simple
c'est assez complexe on sait pas sûr de
qui a un retour véritablement en tout
cas que vous avez
prévu que vous avez plus qu'une une
opinion un avis là-dessus
ce qu'on peut dire c'est deux os environ
comme ma primeur donc nous ce que l'on
voudrait avant tout c'est que ma prime
rénove on est on a bien vu il y a un
enjeu de
d'aide aux financement des ménages donc
il faudrait que ma prime rénov pendant
tous les ans après qu'il y a du monde au
moins d'un milliard si on va être au
rendez-vous et concernant les c2os comme
on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure il faudrait
vraiment qu'un dispositif commun entre
ma prime rénov laisser deux offres à
toutes les mesures qui existent il
faudrait quelque chose qu'on a de
complètement commun et complètement
transparent également donc je pense
voilà c'est une Nord supplémentaire
c'est une une corde supplémentaire à
l'arc mais il faut vraiment que que ça
soit fléché de la même manière que tout
ça soit mis en commun
parler tout à l'heure même d'audit
communes donc pourquoi pas mais il faut
vraiment faut arrêter que ces deux
mondes avec des des fonctionnements
différents voir des audits différents
des demandes de qualification différente
qui qui demeure et puis peut-être
quelque chose est possible qui peut
heurter certains nous adhérents on voit
que selon les entreprises qui vont
chercher des œufs elles ont pas le même
montant selon qu'elles sont pour le même
projet donc une vraie concurrence
déloyale etc donc je pense qu'il est
important de remettre la et que ces deux
c'est deux dispositifs dans le même sens
quand il y avait des coups de pouce
au-delà du montant qui était c'était au
moins mon temps fixe en tant qu'étaient
clair pour l'artisan pour l'entrepreneur
et pour son client le fait la connaît
des C2 avec des prix qui varient en
permanence ne facilite vraiment pas les
choses et d'autant plus que les règles
changent en permanence pour nous c'est
vraiment très compliqué on a vu sous
l'isolation des combles on a une chute
très très forte du marché quand les
fiches ont été modifiées et on a
vraiment des entreprises qui ont qui
avait investi là-dedans qui sont
retrouvés très mal
juste en complément on partage
évidemment cette analyse c'est d'une
complexité incroyable sans cohérence
avec le dispositif RGE on a eu de cesse
de rajouter des exigences ces piloter de
manière totalement à part juste deux
petits exemples pour faire comprendre
l'absurdité une entreprise qui est
contrôlée dans le cadre des C2E le
résultat du contrôle est bon son client
n'est pas nécessairement payé et
entreprise non plus parce que son petit
camarade d'à côté a peut-être eu un
problème sur son chantier et la manière
dont on dépose les dossiers ces deux
œufs fait que tout le paquet qui est
déposé est bloqué c'est impossible à
expliquer à une entreprise que son
chantier est bon qu'il a été contrôlé et
pour retourner les pas payé parce que
d'autres n'ont pas bien fait le boulot
et deuxième exemple toutes les adresses
en France il en reste encore un certain
nombre qui n'ont pas de numéro de rue ou
de route on demande à l'entreprise de
fournir un extrait cadastral
[Musique]
un bon programme mais encore une fois on
crée un programme pour accompagner et
pour expliquer les textes qui sont qui
sont compliqués donc si on pouvait déjà
d'abord simplifier les textes ça
éviterait d'investir des des sommes
folles pour aller expliquer les textes
enfin voilà c'est une parenthèse même si
on suicide du programme Oscar mais si on
pouvait simplifier avant de créer des
choses pour aller expliquer c'est un peu
dommage
alors est-ce que parmi nos collègues il
y aurait des questions
non monsieur le rapporteur est-ce que
vous auriez
quelques questions en suspens
non vous l'avez déjà un peu répondu sur
notamment là je me reste plutôt à la
cape c'est vrai qu'on entend souvent
justement le la grosse problématique de
des lourdeurs administratives quoi en
fait et du temps passé pour des petites
entreprises parfois individuelles sur le
temps administratif et voilà et pas sur
le chantier et pas sur la réalisation
bon vous l'avez dit à travers les C2E et
mais comment dire votre votre dispositif
idéal ça serait quoi en fait enfin c'est
de se dire comment justement à partir de
mon moment bah oui il y a une aide
publique forcément il faut bien du coup
contrôler cette aide donc forcément ça
nécessite quelques quelques documents et
quelques engagements mais enfin voilà ce
que du coup vous avez un petit peu un
dispositif qui permettrait justement par
rapport à toutes ces lourdeurs qui
soient beaucoup plus simple en tout cas
et plus facile à mettre en oeuvre ça a
été dit tout à l'heure par le Président
c'est à dire il y a le dispositif RGE
d'une part
qui doit être conservé pour les
entreprises qui ont une certaine
activité et qui donc vont avoir plus
l'habitude de traiter les dossiers et
autres etc de répondre à un certain
nombre d'exigences administratives et
pour les autres entreprises plutôt plus
petites deux trois salariés qui font
deux trois chantiers le contrôle type
consuel en fin de chantier consuel c'est
ultra simple pour remplissez un CERFA et
puis après vous êtes contrôlés ou pas
suivant le nombre de chantiers que vous
réalisez donc c'est à notre sens la
bonne manière de répondre et d'englober
le maximum d'entreprises celles qui en
font un choix vont aller vers le RGE
parce qu'elles ont l'activité suffisante
et les autres on les contrôle en fin de
chantier ce qui est au passage est bien
pour le pouvoir public parce que ça
élimine la fraude dans ce secteur là et
ça lui donne une garantie que l'argent
est bien investi sur des travaux de
qualité
que je vous avais rajouté sur les RGA
pour moi il y a quelque chose qui qui
est hyper important c'est vraiment j'en
ai déjà parlé plusieurs fois mais il
faut vraiment des mesures concrètes pour
lutter parce que voilà on entend
beaucoup on allume là on allume la télé
on parle c'est vraiment à charge en
disant la plupart des travaux aidés sont
mal fait on a quand même 90%, vous avez
vu dans les contrôles les gens qui sont
satisfaisants ensuite il y a des il y a
des zones il y a des zones à risque etc
qui sont identifiés qui sont améliorés
voilà mais globalement c'est toute quand
on travaille illégal encore une fois on
parle de ce qui va pas et mais même ça
peut même pas même le parler du marché
qui doit être présent mais ça met
également le doute
dans des personnes qui seraient prêtes à
s'engager dans une rénovation
énergétique non mais qu'est-ce qui va
m'arriver comment je fais que c'était
donc je pense que ça c'est vraiment un
élément crucial quand je vois
qu'aujourd'hui qualifications qui ont
fait des audits qui savent fertinemment
que les entreprises ne sont pas dans les
clous alors enlève le RGE il faut savoir
je pense qu'elle vous l'ont dit on a
aujourd'hui des spécialistes sur la
place des avocats spécialisés les oblige
à les reprendre en disant comment vous
pouvez enlever une entreprise qui fait
des milliers de chantiers avec
simplement cinq contrôles donc elles
sont obligées de les réintégrer et en
plus elle leur demande des dommages
intérêts donc voilà donc je pense que
au-delà de tout ce qu'on a dit et donc
du coup qu'est-ce qu'on fait on renforce
les critères de RGE et là je vous
rejoins on renforce les critères
et c'est pas renforçant les critères
pour à destination des entreprises
vertueuses qu'on lutte contre le travail
illégal parce que eux de toute façon ils
ont toujours un coup d'avance et ça
faire pour donc je pense que c'est c'est
vraiment un enjeu très très fort on a on
a fait des propositions avec des on a
dit des fichiers communs entre l'an et
ces deux hommes apprimonables et encore
une fois que ce sont des contrôles
aléatoires et qu'on sache que telle
entreprise fait des centaines ou des
milliers de travaux et donc un nombre
d'audits suffisants par les vérifier ses
chantiers voilà je pense j'assiste un
petit peu sur cette et encore une fois
un enregistrer je veux pas dire qu'il y
en a beaucoup mais vraiment sans ça ça
pollue ça pollue un parce que de notre
côté tous ces boîtes vertueuses qui le
font bien on a l'impression qu'elles ne
sont pas deuxièmement ça freine c'était
l'endroit de rénovation énergétique
parce que je me mets à la place du
particulier ce qui se dit j'ai fait un
élastique on a tous vu des photos il y a
des murs qui sont à peine qui sont
commencés qui sont pas finis des
produits qui sont pas appropriés donc ça
c'est important et puis je pense
également qu'il faut qu'on soit assez
sévère qui est qu'on sache exactement
qui réalisent des travaux l'entreprise
qui est bénéficie des aides doit être
RGE pour moi c'est c'est important et
ensuite on doit savoir si elle sous
traite on doit limiter le rang de
sous-traitance on doit savoir qui
effectivement fait les travaux j'insiste
surtout ce champ là mais je pense que on
parlait d'argent public on doit rendre
des comptes mais je pense qu'un des
moyens de rendre des comptes c'est
vraiment de de se mettre en ordre de
marche pour lutter contre ses fronde
de ce point-là on a le dispositif
accompagnateur je pense que dans le
dispositif non dans l'architecture si
j'ose dire c'est un peu le tiers de
confiance bon donc faut voir comment ce
dispositif va se mettre en place il est
tout nouveau
on a eu un long débat au sein du C2E et
je vais m'en faire écho ici parce que je
pense qu'il est important
évidemment pour les artisans qui sont
aussi des qui donnent aussi du conseil
ce dispositif est parfois mal perçu
disons clairement les choses parce que
même se disent bon on pourrait aussi
faire le finalement on pourrait faire le
travail bon en tous les cas et par
ailleurs les artisans et je pense qu'ils
ont raison ne veulent pas non plus être
comment dirais-je des sous-traitants au
fond d'un accompagnateur qui déciderait
pour eux bon donc c'est quand même un
sujet qui qui alors
l'état l'a un peu traité en permettant à
des
opérateurs qui réalisent des travaux de
créer des filiales pour être
accompagnateur
nous avons introduit mais c'est un c'est
un c'est une comment dirais c'est une
disposition qui a été votée de manière
très très faiblement majoritaire au
csc2e nous avons introduit l'idée que
dans cette hypothèse
un
accompagnateur ne pourrait pas réaliser
des travaux sur un chantier où la maison
mère serait
opérateur voilà donc je le dis justement
pour que ce dispositif garde
cette cette capacité de tiers de
confiance mais on voit bien quand même
la difficulté au passage quand même
c'est vrai aussi pour les
diagnostiqueurs
on voit bien la difficulté de créer le
service public
avec des opérateurs privés
qu'on va rémunérer mais pas pas
énormément non plus soyons clairs un DPE
ça va ça coûte ça va c'est 150 euros
ça 150 euros donc la plupart du temps le
la personne ne se déplacera même pas à
faire ça par téléphone elle va
renseigner si elle a pas les si elle a
pas les bonnes indications elle va
mettre des indications par défaut qui
vont tout de suite faire évidemment
exploser le DPE quand vous voyez par
ailleurs la conséquence que ça peut
avoir pour le propriétaire qui peut plus
louer son bien ou même plus le vendre
enfin bon donc tout ça et quand même un
peu exorbitant bon donc c'est des
dispositifs qu'il faut qu'il faut
renforcer c'est à dire les
diagnostiqueurs les accompagnateurs
si on veut que le système soit contrôlé
soit soit bien cont rôlées puissent les
accompagnatures pourraient très bien de
être ceux qui qui délivent l'attestation
à la sortie par exemple donc il y a un
travail à faire sur pour bien comment
dirais-je compléter le dispositif et le
rendre plus plus sécurisant
si vous n'avez de votre côté rien
d'autre à rajouter par rapport à des
points que nous n'aurions pas
directement évoqué de toute façon si au
vu du questionnaire quand vous avez fait
passer vous aviez des compléments à nous
communiquer n'hésitez pas à les faire
remonter vers la Commission et on vous
remercie très sincèrement d'avoir
participé à cette audition à cette table
ronde sur la construction qui était fort
intéressante et je vous souhaite une
bonne fin de journée merci beaucoup à
vous merci